thank you very much for being here
appreciate it I'm thrilled to be with a
very very important man
in Guatemala the Minister Enrique
degenhardt we are doing a very important
signing it's a historic Asylum or safe
third agreement between our two
countries very important event we've
long been working with Guatemala and now
we can do it the right way it's going to
be terrific for them and terrific for
the United States this landmark
agreement will put the Coyotes and the
smugglers out of business these are bad
people who's a very very bad sick
deranged people will make a lot of money
off other people's misery is going to
provide safety for legitimate asylum
seekers and stop asylum fraud and abuse
system is also transformative in the
step it will take and many many many
steps it will take forward security
safety for Guatemala and signifies the
incredible bright future for their
country this agreement will usher in a
new year of investment and growth for
their nation and sets the stage for
cooperation between our countries and
expanding access to the h-2a visa which
easier agricultural workers and farm
workers we're going to have them coming
into our country in a easier fashion
than even before it's very important for
our business or our farms or our ranches
and we are going to make that a very
very much easier less cumbersome program
and further bilateral investment will
take place but the
h-2a is really going to be streamlined
and all of those workers that come in we
want them to continue to come in and you
know we have a very low rate of
unemployment record-setting we're at
about 3.5 maybe 3.6 I hear it's going
down probably will because the country's
doing a tremendous business had another
record stock market today we're sending
a clear message to human smugglers and
traffickers that your day is over and
we're investing in the future of
Guatemala the safety of migrants and
their families will protect the rights
of those with legitimate claims and will
end the widespread abuse of the system
and the crippling crisis on our border
I want to thank Mexico as you know
Enrique the Mexican government the
President of Mexico has now 21,000
troops on our double borders on their
border by you they have about six
thousand and an hour southern border
they have getting close to 20,000 by
itself it's going to probably be about
26,000 people totally soldiers and very
good ones that set a tremendous impact
really an incredible impact so Kevin if
you look at what's happened over the
last short period of time it's it's
really been great
now if the Democrats would sign
something it would be a lot easier but
we have to do it around the Democrats
because they refuse to want to close up
the borders they want open borders that
means smugglers it means hijackers it
means drugs it means crime it's frankly
a disgrace but with Guatemala with
Mexico and with other countries that
will be signing safe third agreements
very shortly we're doing really well I
want to thank if I might Enrique the
president of Guatemala president Morales
please give them my regards and thank
you very much he's a terrific guy we we
like him very much and we've worked
together really really well so
YouTube gentleman would sit down Kevin
and Ricky and you'll side I'll stand
right behind you
this way I'll confirm it
so that's a very big thing it's very
important signature never been done
before
thank you very much look we've been
dealing for many years I would say with
Guatemala and with other countries and
we are now at a point where we are we
just get along and they're doing well
we've asked them to do and I think it's
gonna be a great thing for Guatemala
they don't want these problems either so
we were able to get this done and we got
it done fairly quickly but this is after
many many years Mexico also is working
along with us very nicely I mean semaine
dysley actually you'll see a chart where
the numbers are really through the
through the floor I should say because
they're going down Kevin maybe you want
to speak to the numbers how well we're
doing in terms of apprehensions
absolutely mr. president since the
agreement was signed with Mexico that
you energized and drove we've had 28
percent reduction in June and we're
headed toward another 22 percent
reduction in July in crossing so 43
percent overall thanks for the effort on
the government Mexico side and the
implementation of our migrant protection
protocols border wide and the fact that
they do have really big slowdown coming
in from Guatemala at the border because
we have again 6,000 Mexican troops at
the border of Guatemala so that helps
but this will really help this is
something that's going to be rather
incredible so the numbers are going to
we we could really do this in a much
easier fashion if we had cooperation
from the deaf
so we have absolutely no cooperation
nobody can understand most of these
people five years ago they all wanted a
wall and we're building a lot of wall
right now a lot of it we've ripped out
old wall and we ripped out wall that
didn't even exist which was it had bad
footings bad foundations it was they
used to be a wall there there wasn't it
was gobbled up by the people that
crossed and we're building beautiful new
wall a lot of it and it's getting built
rapidly so a lot of things are happening
but this is a very this is a very big
day John focus at the Democrats today
was to say that they are going to
continue and expand their investigation
they're looking for the grand jury
testimony behind the Moller report they
want to try and enforce the subpoena
against Don began what do you say I
think it's a disgrace what the Democrats
are doing it's it's so sad to see what
their how they're impeding all of the
good things that we're doing like as an
example today is the border and we're
strengthening up our border with a great
country and we have other great
countries that are going to be signing
on also and we're doing this all because
the Democrats won't give us what we need
so simple get rid of the loopholes work
with Asylum it would take a very short
period of time they won't do it all they
want to do is impede they want to
investigate they want to go fishing and
I watch Bob Muller and they have nothing
there's no collusion there's no
obstruction they have nothing it's a
disgrace we want to find out what
happened with the last Democrat
president let's look into Obama the way
they've looked at me from day one
they've looked into everything that
we've done they could look into the book
deal that President Obama made
let's subpoena all of his records let's
subpoena all of the records having to do
with Hillary Clinton and all the
nonsense that went on with Clinton and
her foundation and everything else we
could do that all day long
frankly the Republicans were
gentlemen and women when we had the
majority in the House they didn't do
subpoenas all day long they didn't do
what they what these people have done
what they're doing is a disgrace so
destructive to our country and I think
that's why we're going to take back the
house that's why we're easily going to
hold the presidency and we're going to
continue to hold the Senate and you know
people don't say but we picked up two
seats of the Senate we went from 51 to
53 in the 18 election nobody says they
talk about the house and I didn't get
the campaign very much for the house I
couldn't because we were campaigning for
the Senate we almost picked up five
seats you know that very well so it's a
disgrace that they're doing it they're
doing it for political reasons and most
of them many of them are admitting that
it's politics and frankly it's a very
sad thing for our country yes looking at
the whole cookie situation you know
they've ordered 125 have 35 fighter jets
billions and billions of dollars they've
paid some of it the planes are being
made they're easily sold to other
nations because of the greatest fighter
jet in the world and we have a backlog
of orders but it's a tough situation
they are getting the s400 and the our
statutes and everything else says you do
that you just can't order this equipment
and generally speaking you can't order
equipment period I don't blame Turkey
because there are a lot of circumstances
and a lot of a lot of a lot of problems
that occurred during the Obama
administration this states back to the
Obama administration which was a
disaster okay yes
we were not going in the right direction
well I think I asked maybe Kevin and
Ricky and show relationships we stayed
at the table we've been working on and
throughout Enrique's demonstrated a
tremendous commitment the minister of
government for autumn Allah helping lead
the region to take responsibility for
migration flows to work together with
the United States on how we can take the
power away from the criminal
organizations that are exploiting these
vulnerable migrants and we just stayed
we stayed with it and got over the line
I would say that Walla Walla is
definitely clear and the responsibility
that it has we are clear that we have to
make changes and the way to do it is
working together with our best ally
that's what we're showing here today and
we are definitely committed to continue
to win and improving what we have your
court said that this was not possible no
they didn't say that so what the court
said which is a provisional injunction
was basically defined the process that
was it had to be followed we as
Secretary michaleen and mention a little
while ago
define how to do that procedure and we
are going to implement it so this is a
return to the appropriate approach with
it under international law to protecting
asylum seekers at the earliest possible
point in their journey if we have a
Honduran family or an El Salvadoran
national instead of having to pay
smuggler come all the way to our border
to seek asylum when they arrive in
Guatemala they're in a country that has
a fair proceeding for assessing asylum
claims and that's where they should make
that claim that returns that understand
under international law so they can make
a protection claim if they would like in
Guatemala so if they arrive in the US
not having availed themselves of that
opportunity they'll be returned to go on
them all it's a it's a claim for a
protection under international law for
asylum which we've never had before and
which is something that's so good good
for everybody
but it's simply well we have a great
agreement with Mexico but we're gonna
probably do some additional work on it
because we can't get anything from the
Democrats dealing with Mexico is really
what Mexico is doing for us at the
border is far greater than what the
Democrats have done you know the amazing
thing about the Democrats it was all
fine everything was great four or five
years ago before I was president and now
they think we're gonna win so they're
doing everything they can with the
impeachment nonsense we had no
obstruction yet no collusion
you know obstruction sort of interesting
they've interviewed 500 people they've
interviewed lawyers they've interviewed
everybody that they wanted to interview
people that had I could have kept back
by using presidential privilege I could
have kept back everybody they didn't
have to interview anybody I gave them
total and then they say obstruction
these people and clowns
the Democrats have clowns they're being
left at all over the world and I watched
this morning I watched Nancy Pelosi
trying to get through that with the
performance that Robert Muller put on
where I don't think he ever read the
agreement or the document and the
document said no collusion they don't
even talk about that so there was no
crime they said well there was no crime
but he obstructed how do you obstruct
there's no crime but actually was worse
than that because it was a phony crime
that they put on the crime was what they
put on but I watched Muller for two and
a half years we've watched this and
that's the best they have and it's a
disgrace and the world is laughing at
him and unfortunately it's so bad for
our country it's
our relationships with other countries
including Russia there's no reason we
shouldn't get along with Russia there's
no reason we shouldn't get along with
other countries and one of the things
that's nice about Guatemala's we've
never had a better relationship right
now they've agreed to do something
that's very good for the United States
and we're going to work with them also
we're going to be it's going to be a
partnership and it's happening with
Mexico - we never had any kind of
cooperation with Mexico ever until this
president frankly and and my presidency
well you have maybe 21,000 be 26,000
soldiers and it's so good for Mexico
because they're killing they're getting
rid of the cartels which everybody knows
they've been running big portions of
Mexico and and the Coyotes and all of
these terrible people Mexico has done a
great job for their people the president
has done a great job for his people and
president Morales has done a great job
by doing this because now he has a
friend in the United States instead of
an enemy of the United States yes I
might I'm so friends put on a attacks on
our companies you know that and wrong
wrong thing to do they should not have
done it so I may do that I may
I've always liked American wines better
than French ones even I don't drink wine
I just like the way they look okay but
the American wines are great American
wines are great and they didn't do the
right thing when they start taxing Eric
companies we tax our companies they
don't tax our companies so France did
that I told them I said don't do it
because if you do it I'm going to tax
your wine mean tariff or tax code or
whatever you want so yeah we're working
on that right now
wrong you were critical of my brother's
decision to do this how is that
relationship I just spoke to no I just
spoke to I have a good relationship with
president McGrath
but they shouldn't have done this they
used to taken advantage of the United
States but not with me as president look
I look at deals that were done with
other presidents in this country and
it's a disgrace that our country's
allowed this to happen with China for
years and years and years was making
from 300 billion to five hundred and
seven billion dollars a year okay
now we're taking in billions of dollars
from China and it's all turning around
whether a deal is made you know they're
going next week they're more meetings
meeting after meeting I don't think
personally China would sign a deal if I
had a 2% chance of losing the election I
think China would probably say let's
wait let's wait maybe Trump will loser
we could deal with another dope or
another stiff like the people that
allowed these deals to happen this this
horrible thing to happen to our country
because what's happened to our country
the money that China has taken out of
the United States has rebuilt China and
I don't blame China I blame the United
States for allowing that to happen so if
I'm President Xi or if I'm frankly Iran
and Iran wants to make a deal I can tell
you that right now
but if I'm Iran I'll probably say man if
I can hold out I'm going to wait for a
sleepy Jill Biden instead of trouble cuz
sleepy Joe we can make any deal we want
with him he doesn't know what's
happening so what else we'll be
announcing it sometime fairly soon
we'll see what happens but they put a
tax on we said don't do it we tax on
companies you know tax our companies and
we'll be announcing something it might
be a wine it might be on something else
but we'll be it's called reciprocal it's
a reciprocal tax and you will be
announcing that fairly soon then it
makes sense Jon do you agree with that
you're a man you're a man that enjoys
wine you just won't
enjoy French wine anymore I think that
China will probably say let's wait it's
1415 months of the election let's see if
what are these people that give the
United States away let's see if one of
them could possibly get elected and I'll
tell you what when I win like almost
immediately they're all gonna sign deals
and they're going to be phenomenal deals
for the country but so I don't know that
they're gonna I don't I don't know if
they're gonna make a deal maybe they
will maybe they won't I don't care
because we're taking in tens of billions
of dollars worth of tariffs and the
farmers are happy because I gave them 16
billion dollars out of the tariffs and
had tremendous you know much more than
that leftover as you know tremendous
amount of money left over like five
three times and we haven't even taxed
China yet compared to what I could do so
we have tens of billions of dollars
rolling in from China we never had ten
cents coming in and again I don't blame
President Xi I blame our past leaders
for allowing it to happen for so many
years with the World Trade Organization
China was totally flatlined and when the
World Trade Organization came about and
China joined the World Trade they became
a rocket ship because you know it's a
very unfair situation that took place at
the World Trade Organization as are many
of them so so they're gonna go and we'll
talk we'll see I don't personally care
that much because we're getting billions
and billions remember this - people
aren't paying but everyone says people
pay for it
China's devalued their currency and
they're putting money in their pumping
money into their society into their
country like you wouldn't believe
you caught quantitative easing with us
we have a Fed that does quantitative
tight
in the raise interest rates so we have a
normalize rate President Obama had no
rates and he had no tightening and we
still have a much better economy than in
his wildest dreams so and there was
something okay about that but we the Fed
acted too soon I turned out to be right
they acted too soon and too violently
we've had nine increases I believe
you'll check that but I believe it's
nine increases a couple of under couple
under her and a lot under Powell I'm not
a fan okay very strong the country is
very strong the dollar is a it's a
beautiful thing in one way but it makes
it harder to compete and despite that
but we have a very powerful dollar so
that's the good news
despite that we're doing really well and
the country is doing well it has really
become more than ever before the
currency of choice you know you have the
euro that tried to cut in while the euro
is now not doing so well Europe is not
doing so well China is not doing very
well you look at other countries with a
hottest economic country in the world
there's nobody close even Guatemala want
to do business with us now so we're
happy yes right I could do that in two
seconds if I want and why did you do oh
I didn't say well I'm not going to do
something but I'm you know look having a
strong dollar there's a reason that it
sounds so good and having the strong
dollars having the strong dollar we have
an amazing country of a very strong
country that's why our country and has a
strong currency other countries have a
currency that's down the tubes it's a
currency that's weak China's currency is
very lovely you look at other countries
look at the Euro the earth so low I mean
Germany is paying almost no interest
we're paying two point one percent we're
paying a lot of interest that's because
we have the strong currency it's very
complicated formula for something
well it's not complicated for me the
Federal Reserve raised the rates too
fast and too soon and they shouldn't
have done quantitative tightening which
they did if they didn't do that we would
be at four point five percent and set a
two point one everybody's so thrilled
with two point what we could add it much
more except for the Federal Reserve and
we could have been five to ten thousand
points higher in the Dow now I don't
want to sound too upset about it because
we just broke the all-time record in the
history of our country of the Dow but we
could have been higher right could have
been a contender could have been higher
as Marlon would say Marlon Brando the
great Marlon Brando yes well you said it
there short range missiles and my
relationship is very good with Chairman
Kim and we'll see what happens but they
are short range missiles and many people
have those missiles no not at all he
didn't say a warning to the United
States and can tell you that he didn't
say a warning to the United States but
they have their disputes the two of them
have their disputes for a long time but
he didn't say that but they are
short-range missiles had very standard
missiles mr. president have you spoken
with Morris it's the best question we've
ever asked well you know why your timing
is good because I spoke to him about how
long have you been here in 16 minutes
I've spoke to him 17 minutes ago I hung
up the phone as you're coming in and
he's a good guy he's a friend of mine I
think we're gonna have a great
relationship and Boris is gonna be a
great Prime Minister I predict you will
be a great Prime Minister he has what it
takes
they needed him for a long time UK
needed him for a long time and
let's see what happens yeah hopefully he
and I will spend a lot of we just spent
a lot of time when I was with the Queen
within one of the great most beautiful
couple of days that I've ever
experienced she's a tremendous woman
incredible woman we get along very well
so Horace and I just spoke I
congratulated him and he's all set to go
he's gonna be I think it would do a
great job we're working already on a
trade agreement and I think it'll be a
very substantial trade agreement you
know we can do with the UK we can do
three to four times we were actually
impeded by their relationship with the
European Union we were very much
impedance on trade and I think we can do
three to four or five times what we're
doing we don't do the kind of trade we
could do with what some people say is
Great Britain and some people remember a
word you don't hear too much as the word
England which is a piece of it but with
the UK we could do much much more trade
and we expect to do it okay well I want
a pelear plants in the United States I
don't want to build them in China so
what I heard they got to build in China
I said it's okay you could build in
China but when you send your product
into the United States we're going to
tear a few but we'll work it out a man I
have a lot of liking for and respect is
Tim Cook and we'll work it out I think
they're going to announce that they got
to build a plant in Texas and if they do
that I'm starting to get very happy
I do I do indeed
pretty soon I mean we get quick
agreements so I just want to end up by
saying that Guatemala has been really a
pleasure to deal with and we're gonna
have a great relationship for many years
to come
and I'd like you please extend my
warmest regards to the people of
Baltimore what other way bed mints is
not a vacation I don't go to Manhattan
because when I go to Manhattan I you
know I stay at Trump Tower and after
close up the whole city of banana so I
go to bed mixer which is a beautiful
place but it's never a vacation it's
working I hope not because I like more
people I'd rather be right here you know
but probably over should freedom a lot
of times you go and they do a lot of
work in the White House for instance the
Obama administration worked out a brand
new air conditioning system for the West
Wing and it was so good
before they did the system now that they
did the system it's freezing or hot in
here not extended but for a short period
of time
hey you know meaning like less than a
week but again I do I do that just
officially just to put out of the record
I do that because when I go in to Trump
Tower they close up ten blocks around
the building and it's Manhattan New York
City it's a big I don't want to
inconvenience people I don't get any
credit for that but that's ok where's
big mitts everybody you know what's that
very easily it so much easier it's a
much easier thing it's a great place but
I would love to go to Manhattan I just
don't like seeing the city close up I've
had to suffer living in Manhattan I've
had to suffer gravely as presidents
would come in and come out and the
entire city would be shut down
so I guess I understand it better than
we have the g7 coming up kids we look
forward to Italy and France Sousa stop
we do and this is a stop that we didn't
have planned right here in the Oval
Office with Guatemala and again thank
you very much in ranking thank you
everybody